[Musique]
l'aspect road trip m'a vraiment actiris
et un film qu'on suit une jeune fille de
8 ans qui part pour rester premières
vacances avec son père à bord d'un truc
18 roues les rams au début du film on
sent une mésentente entre le père et sa
fille des roumains immigrés récemment à
montréal où la relation parfait moi
c'est ce qui m'a vraiment touché
personnellement
[Musique]
cas de nécessité
est-ce que ça va bien aller ça veut dire
pas bien les déceptions les moments qui
essaie de rattraper dont on compare avec
une histoire très humaine qui ensuite
ouvre son et sujets plus profonds
les deux complices n'en parle jamais
mais le thème de l'immigration survient
à chaque virage renouveau regard d'un
enfant qui découvre un peu ce sujet le
un peu trop tôt peut-être aussi mais qui
découvre la situation de l'immigration
puis aussi des différentes manières ne
sait pas on parle de l'immigration des
fois comme une masse d ingram et c'est
tout le monde
toute la petite histoire donc c'était
moi ce qui m'a attiré la danse et la
possibilité du mend est sujet au fil des
kilomètres
l'ambiance dans le camion se transforme
l'inquiétude du père les frustrations de
la fillette qui voit les plages des
filets sans s'y arrêter ou à peine
quelques mois
tu
m
une fois à destination les vacances au
mexique ne dure qu'une nuit papa les
deux voyageurs repartent vers le nord
avec une cargaison mystérieuse
[Musique]
c'est par empathie est ce que c'est par
besoin d'argent est pourquoi il en train
de s'affairer là dedans aussi sur ce
geste illégal
on se pose des questions autant que la
petite fée s'impose et puis ça permet
justement encore une fois d'humaniser ce
sujet le tuer vous transporte sur nous
[Musique]